[Musique]
les premiers témoins ont commencé à
défiler cette semaine devant la
commission sur l'état d'urgence le juge
Paul Roulot doit déterminer s'il était
justifié par le gouvernement Trudeau
d'invoquer la Loi sur les mesures
d'urgence pour mettre fin à l'occupation
du centre-ville d'Ottawa en février
dernier cet examen pourrait donner des
pistes de solutions autorités si elles
étaient de nouveau confrontées à Paris
circonstances j'en ai discuté avec le
conseil municipal de tawa Mathieu Fleury
dont le quartier a été occupé pendant 24
jours
monsieur Fleury bonjour bonjour Mathieu
Fleury conseil municipal de du
centre-ville en plein centre-ville
d'Ottawa dans le secteur de la rue
Rideau là où on a vu le gros des impact
de la manifestation des opposants
mesures sanitaires l'hiver dernier
parlez moi un peu de ce que c'était ici
à l'époque pour vous on s'attendait à
l'arrivée des camionnettes qui avait
voyagé le Canada pour arriver à la
colline parlementaire
camion arrive où on vit le premier
week-end ok c'était Rohff il y a eu
beaucoup de klaxonnements beaucoup de
d'émotions à travers cette première
longue fin de semaine là on arrive le
lundi matin sont encore là d'accord ça
bouge pas on sent que d'autres camions
qui s'y ajoute positionnement des
camions les commerces ont fermé à cette
époque là on parle du centre rideau
marché-bail mais là tout seul il y a
d'autres commerces qui ferment parce que
plus d'achat endage alors là on se
retrouve en début de première semaine
avec beaucoup de questions quelles
seront les stratégies puis on voit tout
de suite la Ville d'Ottawa abandonne un
peu ses responsabilités vers l'autorité
du chef de police qui lui semble mener
avec une main de femme et peu d'actions
est occupé pendant 24 jours
le gouvernement fédéral finit par
invoquer la Loi sur les mesures
d'urgence est-ce que c'était nécessaire
d'après vous
je connais pas les détails fin de cette
utilisation là mais les actions sur le
terrain ça doit vraiment pouvoir avoir
les équipes policières à travers le pays
qui ont qui ont enlevé les manifestants
qui à ce moment-là
occupaient le territoire avait un impact
réel sur les résidents du centre ville
d'Ottawa sur les commerçants pour nous
ça résolu le problème bon la commission
d'enquête sur l'utilisation de la Loi
sur les mesures d'urgence se pencher
là-dessus vous vous attendiez à quoi de
cette commission là pour nous à la ville
c'est premièrement faisons un
reflet complet de la situation qui a
pris les décisions à quel moment quelle
décision n'ont pas été prise puis on
crée le problème qu'on a permis les
camions de venir dans les
centre-ville devant le Parlement ça a
été le premier la première mauvaise
décision du chef de police d'après moi
j'imagine qu'on va pouvoir vraiment voir
l'ensemble de ces décisions là par la
suite pour nous résidents local qui
vivent qui vivent dans la capitale
comment on peut faire pour prévenir ce
genre d'éléments-là dans la capitale pas
enlever les manifestations on en a eu
plusieurs depuis mais comment on peut
s'assurer que les résidents puissent
vivre dans le centre-ville d'Ottawa je
les commerçant plus demeurer ouvert
malgré les différentes périodes mariées
malgré les différentes manifestations
comment comment on peut faire ça d'après
vous
je pense que quelques éléments moi comme
représentants des résidents d'Ottawa nos
taxes foncières payent pour la police
locale cette police-là qui danse
contexte si a été appelé à faire des
choses extraordinaires à l'extérieur
vraiment de leur mandat puis pour moi
c'est là où il y a vraiment un débat qui
prend en charge de la colline
parlementaire et des propriétés incluant
les ambassades qui ont une
responsabilité fédérale pour justement
que la police d'Ottawa face à job au
sein des communautés puis la police
d'Ottawa a pu préserver ça à l'extérieur
de ce qu'on considère la zone rouge
durant durant l'occupation le
gouvernement ontarien n'a pas été
convoqué il y a des intervenants
fédéraux qui sont là municipaux des gens
du monde policier
on a toujours cette grande difficulté-là
dans la région
Ottawa Gatineau souvent abandonné au
gouvernement fédéral qui a un mandat
élargi nos provinces nous autant du côté
Outaouais du côté d'Ottawa c'est loin
queenspark c'est loin l'Assemblée
nationale puis leur intervention dans
notre région souvent est abandonné à la
responsabilité fédérale quelle leçon
d'après vous la ville de tawa à tiré de
tout ça même avant qu'on connaisse les
conclusions de la commission est-ce que
vous avez déjà des choses que vous avez
apprises en vous disant on frappe shop
comme ça la vulnérabilité de la ville
comme capitale et significative pour
nous
opérationnellement il y a eu un chaos
complet entre les autorités élus les
autorités de la ville parce qu'on a un
centre de commande d'urgence donc le
modèle est en place mais dès que un
intervention policière on voit comment
c'est pas clair qui prend la
responsabilité puis qui est responsable
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça a laissé
comme trace dans votre
personnellement moi je marche puis
j'entends klaxon puis je dois vous
avouer que on
s'est profond pour nous l'identité de la
ville est impactée j'étais justement
plutôt cette semaine avec tourisme à
tawa qui nous dit eux encore observent
les impacts il y a l'impact de la
pandémie mais à travers tout un impact
de la pandémie ils observe vraiment
un questionnant au niveau de la sécurité
publique je pense que c'est dérivé là à
un impact sur la perception de la
capitale une perception de la ville ça y
est un impact sur vous aussi vous avez
été menacé personnellement votre famille
aussi vous avez décidé que vous de ne
pas vous représenter pour l'instant
après 12 ans comme illuminal pour moi
c'est une pause c'est sûr dans les
discussions au niveau de la jeune
famille on était menacé à la maison
durant cette occupation là ce qui nous a
forcé de déménager puis ça fait partie
des discussions familiales pour
l'instant une petite pause la politique
puis un jour peut-être que la porte
politique de Me réouverte Mathieu Fleury
merci beaucoup merci